ever since the marvel superheroes made
the jump from the comic book page to the
silver screen
there has been one thing that ties them
together more than anything else
the cameo appearances by stan lee but
while comic fans have been spotting the
co-creator of the marvel universe in
random scenes for decades not every
cameo has been
well good here's every marvel movie
cameo by stan the man
ranked from worst to best excelsior true
believers
and rest in peace stan lee we'll miss
seeing you on the big screen
while audiences always look forward to
seeing stan show up in marvel movies
you can't really blame him for skipping
out on this sci-fi channel original film
that was shot on the cheap in australia
that's an awfully long flight for
captain america let alone man thing
instead stan only shows up as a photo as
a missing person
and even then he's nearly impossible to
spawn that said
it's pretty hilarious to imagine stan
having to fight off a swamp monster
even if we didn't get to see it while
you might think stan's cameos are a
mandatory part of anything that hits
theaters with a marvel logo attached to
it
that's not exactly the case he never
appeared in the blade trilogy
and only showed up in about half the
movies in the x-men franchise
it's bad luck then that he missed out on
great mutant theme
movies like logan and x-men first class
instead of skipping out on this one
the cameo itself in which he marvels at
a garden hose defying gravity
is pretty basic and it's nice that stan
could be spotted alongside legendary
x-men writer chris claremont who spent
17 years as the primary writer of those
comics
unfortunately they're both surrounded by
a film that could charitably be called
disappointing turns out that garden hose
was actually more interesting than
anything else going on in that movie the
very first stan lee cameo of the modern
era of marvel movies is mostly
interesting for showing us how far
they've come
these days stan's cameos are an event
unto themselves
but in 2000 the co-creator of the x-men
was a hot dog vendor with
no dialogue in the background of a crowd
scene whose brief appearance was pretty
easy to miss
the avengers was a movie tasked with
making every piece of the mcu up to that
point work together
so it's pretty understandable that most
of its run time was focused on trying to
do that
it's not until after the climax when the
avengers have come together as a team to
save the world from an invading army of
chittari
that lee finally makes his appearance in
a news broadcast
superheroes in new york
it's an easy joke but it works thanks
entirely to lee's effortless charm
one of the recurring gags about stan's
cameos in the mcu movies is that he's
often portrayed as a dirty old man
in iron man 3 that lasciviousness hits
critical mass when we see him judging a
beauty pageant
and getting pretty worked up over the
contestants in the end
not even stan was happy with how his
cameo turned out
my cameo had a couple of scenes in it
that were funny as hell unfortunately
stan's cameo was cut for time
leaving everyone unhappy congratulations
anyhow miss elkridge
it's not my fault really i had nothing
to do with
it stan's first speaking cameo in a
marvel film came in
angley's much-maligned hulk movie in
which he showed up alongside
former hulk actor lou ferrigno as a
security guard
that raises a lot of questions why would
you hire an 81 year old man to be a
security guard
shouldn't he have retired does the stan
lee of this movie's universe need money
so badly that he's willing to take a
potentially dangerous job
look we're not saying stan shouldn't be
in the movie but maybe if that lab had
hired someone else to work security
there wouldn't be so many gamma ray
monsters running around
stan's appearance in this movie was
built entirely around the gag of having
stan lee
show up and say that he knows spider-man
it's almost clever but doesn't quite
work
on one hand stan lee should know
spider-man he co-created the character
and wrote over a hundred issues of his
comic book
on the other hand if he's just talking
about peter parker within the world of
the movie
he should still know who he is he was
the librarian at his high school in the
previous movie
guardians of the galaxy features one of
the only stan lee appearances where the
other characters actually talk about him
in this case he's a victim of rocket's
running commentary on how much he hates
the humanoid population of the planet
xander
identifying him as class a prefer
pretty harsh but maybe rocket saw iron
man 3.
in a movie that otherwise embraces
spider-man's most goopy foe in
all his glory stan's cameo right before
the credits roll in venom is pretty
disappointing
viewers spent the entire run time
waiting to see if their favorite
mustachioed non-agenarian makes an
appearance
only to encounter a scene so unnecessary
that it could have been cut without
anyone ever noticing sure it's fun that
this random dude on the street knows
that eddie brock has a slimy alien space
cannibal living under his skin
but after seeing the same idea done
better elsewhere
it's a letdown is it too much to ask to
see stan the man with giant knives for
fingers
with the first spider-man movie director
sam raimi gave us a scene where stan
actually got to be a hero himself saving
a kid from danger when the green goblin
attacks
not a bad tribute to the guy who wrote
the first hundred issues of spidey's
comic but also nowhere near the fun that
raimi long-time collaborator bruce
campbell got to have in his far
more compelling spider-man cameos stan's
cameo in the second spider-man film is
almost exactly the same as it was the
last time around
a heroic passerby who pulls someone out
of danger during spidey's battle with a
supervillain
the only thing that distinguishes it
from the first one and puts it above it
on our rankings
is what's going on around it
spider-man's first big battle against
doctor octopus
which starts in a bank and winds up
scaling high-rise walls in the middle of
manhattan
it's a great scene even if stan's
appearance feels like a rerun
2003's daredevil movie was memorable for
all the wrong reasons
but stan lee's appearance was one of its
few nice touches in ananda daredevil's
comic book origin
a young matt murdock keeps a distracted
leave from stepping out in front of a
truck
despite his blindness of course that
doesn't explain why they changed
daredevil's origin to take
out the part where he's blinded because
he's saving someone but hey
at least stan fairs better than one of
the movie's other creator cameos
legendary daredevil writer artist frank
miller showed up and got stabbed in the
head with a pen
the second thor movie goes with another
easy gag having lee pop up as a patient
in a mental institution for a quick
laugh
can i have my shoe back as for how he
got in there
we've got a theory maybe this version of
stan is the one who remembers all the
other movies he's made cameos in that
weren't part of the mcu
it's easy to imagine being dragged off
while ranting about the x-men and the
fantastic four
or wondering why nobody in this universe
seems to cuss as much as they did when
he was hanging out with deadpool
seeing three different spider-men in
less than a decade is enough to send
anybody to therapy
homecoming scenes of spider-man
patrolling manhattan and helping out
average new yorkers are some of the
film's finest moments
it shows two important parts of spidey's
personality he's willing to help
everyone with everything
and he's not immune to screwing up on a
pretty regular basis
it's that second part that leads to
lee's appearance as an entire
neighborhood gets together to yell at
our wall crawling hero for making too
much noise in the middle of the day
and also bouncing some poor guy's head
off his own car just for locking his own
keys inside
don't make me come down there it's
pretty appropriate to have stan scolding
spidey too
when you think about it he really kind
of is spider-man's dad
which it turns out is nowhere near as
dangerous as being his uncle
stan lee's best cameos work with the
pretty simple idea of dropping the
comic's lovable grandpa into weird
situations
and ant-man and the wasp is no different
well the 60s were fun but now i'm paying
for it
an older fellow in the famous haight
ashbury district would have probably had
a very specific kind of fun back then
in our world however we know exactly
what lee was doing in the 60s
inventing weird increasingly improbable
situations involving superheroes who
could shrink to the size of ants
trippy enough even without the hippie
help
if you were going to show someone
exactly one stan lee cameo to explain
what he actually does in these movies
this would be the one it's the kind of
joke that could have been done by
anyone but lee being there elevates it
and makes it a little more than just an
exercise in spotting lee in a costume
[Music]
i thought he'd be taller as we saw in
guardians of the galaxy
there seemed to be few things that
superhero filmmakers enjoy more than
casting stan lee as a dirty old man
and he seems to get a kick out of it too
the r-rated deadpool
unsurprisingly takes that to a whole new
level with stan taking the stage as a
strip club dj
while it wasn't on the big screen stan's
earliest marvel movie cameo came in
1989's
trial of the incredible hulk a tv movie
that aired on nbc
it was not only a sequel to the
incredible hulk series
it was also a backdoor pilot for a
daredevil show that never happened
stan's appearance this time is as a jury
foreman present when banner hulks out in
the middle of a trial
his main role here is to just look
surprised but he winds up coming off a
lot better than some of the other jurors
a guy sitting behind him in this scene
decides it's a good idea to throw his
chair at the hulk
dude what are you doing if his cameo in
the first avenger is the archetype
stan's appearance in thor refines it to
something even better
the idea of a bunch of people gathering
around a crater to drink beer and have a
cookout while they all try to pick up a
magic hammer
is great all on its own stan showing up
as the guy who tears his own pickup
truck apart by trying
to drag that hammer out that's great and
even goes to show that the odin power is
even stronger than a chevy silverado
did it work
after the simplicity of stan's cameos in
the first two spider-man
movies his appearance in the third seems
weirdly drawn out
while it was nice to have him in a
speaking role for the first time in the
franchise
the long pause in his line feels strange
you know
i guess one person can make a difference
enough said there is one little twist
though
since it's easy to believe that stan's
playing the same character in all three
spider-man movies
that also means this is a guy who's
previously saved two people's lives
during a super villain attack
could that one person who made the
difference be
stan lee himself sure age of ultron may
be kind of a mess
but the party scene where we get to see
the avengers just hanging out and having
fun
is probably the highlight of the movie
especially since we also get to see stan
show up and get trashed on
thousand-year-old asgardian ale eggshell
forget about thanos and the infinity
stones the biggest payoff in the entire
mcu
comes from stan lee's interactions with
tony stark in their first encounter
tony mistakes him for playboy publisher
and smoking jacket enthusiast hugh
hefner
and takes the first step towards a
pretty amazing payoff
the second time that stan meets tony
stark he's mistaken for larry king
and look no disrespect but that's
actually pretty insulting to stan lee
who has managed to stay spry and wiry
well into his 90s
lee's cameo with ant-man comes as part
of a genuinely awesome scene that gets
some great comedy out of luis and his
winding
fast-paced storytelling as great as this
bit is though
it stings that we're robbed of hearing
stan lee actually say his line here
bartender's all like
yeah crazy stupid fine if there's one
word that describes lee's character in
these movies
it's hapless there's a sort of instant
sympathy you have for this guy
after seeing him tear up his pickup
truck or get clowned on by tony stark
but in winter soldier
you really started to feel bad for him
oh
man i am so fired
this poor guy come on cap you couldn't
just leave a note to help out the
security guards
in what might be his most high brow
cameo to date
lee appears as a bus passenger getting a
kick out of a book
completely oblivious to the mind-bending
reality altering battle going on around
him
the joke lee's book is a copy of the
doors of perception
a memoir detailing aldous huxley's
experience of experimenting with a
hallucinogenic chemical mescaline
it's a strange bit of commentary on the
trippy visuals of the film
but let's be real here if huxley had
seen new york folding in on itself and
an angular man and a cloak of levitation
casting magic spells while he was
tripping out on peyote
he probably wouldn't have been surprised
in thor ragnarok stan makes an
appearance as the barber who cuts thor's
hair to get him ready for his fight with
the hulk
now don't you move my hands aren't as
steady as they used to be
not only does he provide a great
straight man for chris hemsworth's
hilarious blubbering about his precious
golden locks
it also makes perfect sense for someone
looking for game-changing heroes and
villains to be part of the grand
master's gladiatorial games
and it gives stan his best costume ever
the incredible hulk is usually the least
loved entry in the mcu
but its use of lee is one of the best
the film's first major point involves
bruce banner's gamma-irradiated blood
accidentally getting into a soda while
he's working at a bottling plant
temporarily turning anyone who drinks it
into a hulk
and naturally the one poor hulked out
consumer that we see
is stan lee so basically this movie gave
us the idea of stan lee with incredible
hulk powers
the only downside is that we never
actually saw it which might actually be
the biggest oversight in the entire
franchise stan's cameo as peter parker's
school bus driver in infinity war isn't
just good
it's smart what's the matter with you
kids you've never seen a spaceship
before
getting it out of the way early in the
film ensures that audiences would be
paying attention to the
epic interplanetary battle against
thanos rather than keeping an eye out
for everyone's favorite comic book
grandpa
not a bad idea considering how much
there is to keep track of
when every major hero in the mcu is
slugging it out on screen at once
oh no offense ant-man and hawkeye
ant-man
well you haven't heard of me as for what
makes it good
it's absolutely stan's grumpy way too
calm evaluation of the black orders
invasion of earth
if anyone's seen enough spaceships that
it's not even a big deal anymore
it's stan he's been dealing with aliens
invading new york since 1961.
in a sharp contrast to the blurry hot
dog vendor 16 years earlier
x-men apocalypse gave viewers a tight
close-up on stan
using the reflection of his signature
sunglasses to show missiles streaking
through the sky
it's a cool look and it actually uses
stan's physical presence in an
interesting visual
way which is more than you can say for
most of his appearances behind the
scenes though
this is one of the most memorable lee
cameos for a much more bittersweet
reason
it marks the only time that stan
appeared in a film alongside joan
his wife of nearly 60 years sadly she'd
pass away just over a year later
stan's cameo in 2005's fantastic four
marks a huge departure from his usual
roles
for the first time stan was playing a
marvel character that he actually
co-created
willie lumpkin the fantastic four's
mailman
that might not seem like a big deal but
believe it or not willie has been around
for some of the ff's most pivotal
moments
and even dated aunt may as a cheerful
regular guy with a connection to the
entire marvel universe
it's the perfect role for stan it's
almost easy to forget that big hero 6 is
a marvel movie
at least until stan lee shows up at the
end it's a weird cameo though
since lee has virtually no connection to
these characters
big hero 6 was created in 1998 when stan
was
actually briefly out of his marvel
contract at the same time
in a movie where the characters struggle
with older brothers and various other
surrogate father figures
it's nice to know that at least one of
them has a father that we already like
and here's the big iron man payoff after
getting snubbed twice by a man who keeps
mistaking him for others
stan rolls up to the avengers compound
and delivers his own tiny vengeance on
tony stark
are you stank since tony stark is
unquestionably the most famous person in
the entire world
there's no way stan wouldn't be able to
recognize him
tony stank is revenge served cold by a
man who's tired of being mistaken for
hugh hefner and larry king
black panther boasts one of the most
memorable cameos stan has ever done
it happens in the secret casino in south
korea an
incredibly tense moment where t'challa
is at way past bond levels of cool
and three different groups are getting
ready to collide in a massive fight
scene
and then here comes stan casually
pocketing the panthers casino winnings
not like he needs them right you know
what
i think i'll just take these bring them
over here
and hold on for safekeeping having a
wacky action going on in the background
while characters are blissfully unaware
of it is a well-worn gag
but when stan shows up as an oblivious
librarian during one of amazing
spider-man's biggest fights
it's done perfectly what makes it even
better is that after a dozen years of
cameos
this one puts stand front and center for
moviegoers
stan's appearance in teen titans go to
the movies might be the single wildest
cameo
he's ever made this is after all a movie
about superhero movies
and stan's appearance is based on the
idea that the audience is familiar
enough with the tropes of big screen
capes and cowls to catch all the
rapid-fire references
it's funny enough when stan shows up as
a janitor in the warner brothers backlot
it's downright hilarious when he charges
the camera under a neon sign
claiming that it's time for another one
of his subtle cameos
the punchline of his horror struck face
when he realizes he's actually showing
up in the dc movie is just the icing on
the cake
except that it's not really the punch
line that comes later when he crashes
back into the movie
and assures us all that he doesn't care
what movie he's in i'm
back i don't care if it's a dc movie i
love cameos not now stan lee
excelsior for a movie that isn't
remembered all that fondly
2007's fantastic four sequel managed to
include one of the best stan
lee cameos it happens during the wedding
of reed richards and sue storm
uh invitation sir um i should be on that
list
name stanley yeah uh nice try buddy
not only is this the one marvel movie in
which stan smashes through the fourth
wall by actually identifying himself
it's a callback to a similar scene from
one of his greatest comics of all time
fantastic four annual number three where
he's rejected from attending reed
richards and sue storm's wedding
throughout the entirety of the marvel
cinematic universe there's been a
question about whether this was a world
that just happened to be populated by a
bunch of people who look exactly like
stan lee
or if his cameos meant something more in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
we finally find out and it was
everything that a fan theorist could
have wanted
while rocket groot yondu and kraglin are
careening through the galaxy on a series
of warps
we find stan in the depths of space
having a conversation with three of the
watchers the mysterious beings
tasked with chronicling the history of
the universe without ever
interfering themselves anyway before i
was so rudely interrupted
at that time i was a federal express man
it becomes clear that all of these
cameos
really are supposed to be the same guy
in the mcu
stan lee might not be a watcher himself
but he is their most reliable informant
which explains why he's always around
for the universe's most important events